This film in IMAX in three words
emotional, transcendent, breathtaking
What I like about IMAX is because it's
taking up your entire field of view
you're actually choosing what to look at
It's shot and designed so beautifully that
in IMAX that's gonna be pretty intense
There's a tremendous amount of detail
that's gone into this and seeing it in a
large format you can really see it
vividly
It'll be an experience that is something
that people will not easily forget to
see this in IMAX
Everything you see
exists together in a delicate balance
With the sound design you feel immersed
in that environment
I think people will be very excited to
hear Beyonce via the IMAX
What an amazing experience that's gonna
be in IMAX, yeah
You must take your place in the circle of life